Herkese merhaba ben Nisan bugün Sizin
kafanızı şişirmeye geldim kafanızı
şişirmeye Geldim zaten gerçekten yalan
söylemiyorum Çünkü biraz sesler
arasındaki ilişkilerden gürültüyle ses
arasındaki farktan sesler arasındaki
yağışlardan bahsetmek istiyorum size ben
orkestra şafiyim ve günlük hayatta çok
ses dinliyorum insan sesleri bi gürültü
sesleri eşya sesleri etrafındaki her
türlü sesler müzikler ve onların
arasındaki ilişkiler özellikle
hiyerarşik ilişkiler beni çok
heyecanlandırıyor bu tür şeylere çok
tutkuyla yaklaşıyorum 2013'te New York'a
taşındım ve bir ay boyunca bir
arkadaşımın yanında kalıyordum o
arkadaşım da New York'un böyle en
bu sesli gürültülü hiç uyumayan yerinde
yaşıyordu ben ilk o şehre taşındığım da
o gece uyuyamadım Şu mi ki gece Bir
geceden daha farklı değildi yine
uyuyamadım 3. gece artık canıma tak etti
buna bir çözüm bulmam gerekiyor dedim ve
ne yapabilirim diye düşündüm ne
yapabilirim Tabii ki sesleri
dinleyebilirim belki diye düşündüm siren
sesi vardı itfaiyenin siren sesleri
böyle kediye benziyor diye düşündüm o
siren sesleri Ondan sonra biraz daha
rahatlattın kendimi komik buldum bir
tane işte ve uçak sesi vardı uçak sesini
uçak sesi olduğunu anlamamıştım uçak
sesi artık uçak sesiydi ve hemen onu
Hadi bir kategoriye koydum ve kendimi
rahatlattı mum tren sesi vardı prensesin
trenler tren yaparken çok tesis bir ses
çıkarıyormuş bu
Ben bunu Otis sesin trenden geldiğini
Anladım Biraz daha kendimi rahatlattı
mşu mi yorgun 3. günü bana bu deneyimi
yaşattı O günden sonra gerçekten
Hayatımdaki bütün seslere pratik olarak
çok daha farklı yaklaşmaya başladım
bundan önce böyle değildi ama bundan
önce tamam teorik olarak özellikle
lisanslı okurken falan hani böyle yeni
müzikler gürültüler vesaire ile ilgili
Bunlar teorik olarak da içselleştirme
Dini şeyler de özellikle yer ise de
okurken hani böyle bir ses 10 üniversite
bir arası falan gürültü ve ses arasında
çok büyük bir ayrım yapıyordum Hatta bir
adımlarına gidiyordum diyordum ki bazı
müzikler gürültüdür bazı müziklere
gürültüde mi otoritesini kendimde
buluyordum Diyorum ki bu duyduğum
kompozisyon müzik değil Bu bir gürültü
bak
de böyle bir hal değildi Bazen diyordum
ki Tamam bu bir kompozisyon ama olmamış
Kendimde bu otoriteyi buluyordum
Kendimde bu gücü buluyordum kendimde
Böyle bir hak var sanıyordum Peki sesle
gürültüyü ayıran şey Ne bu bariyeri
çektiğimiz zaman birşey gürültü
dediğimiz zaman ne diyoruz gürültü
istenmeyen gürültüyü yüksek sesli
gürültü bizi rahatsız eden bu tarafa
geçtiğimiz zamanda ses var ses uyumlu
ses Tatlıses bizi rahatlatan ses müzik
olabilen melodi olabilen ensesi
seviyoruz gürültülü sevmiyoruz gürültü
yanında kalsın biz bu bölgede çektiğimiz
anda Diyoruz ki ben otobüsteyim ve bu
taraftakiler istenmeyen şeyler
taraftakiler sussun bu taraftakiler
güzelce
biz bunları seviyoruz sen konuşmaya
devam et sen ses çıkarmaya devam et sen
en sevilen istenilen şeysin Peki bir
adım daha atalım etrafımızdaki şeyler
etrafımızdaki sesler günlük
hayatımızdaki sesler ile gürült
arasındaki bağlantı ne Siz hiç haksız
yere iş arkadaşınızdan daha daha az
aldığınız maaşı eşitlemek için
patronunuza gittiğimizde aza yediniz mi
var ya da protesto etmek için Sokağa
çıktığımızda sivrisinekler gibi sprey
gazı sıkıldım üzerinize yada sırf cinsel
tercihiniz yüzünden tartaklandı nız mı
abone ol
Bu sesle gürültü arasındaki farkı ayıran
o bariyeri koyun otorite ile bizi
tartaklayan cinsel yönelim izinden iş
vermeyen cinsiyetimiz yüzünden azarlayan
düşüncelerimiz yüzünden hapse atan
otorite aynı güç Biz diyoruz ki sen
istenmeyen sinsen toplumun vızıltı
tarafında yer alıyorsun sen ağzını
açtığın zaman biz seni kabul etmiyoruz
seni dinlemek istemiyoruz seni
anlamıyoruz Sen çok karmaşık sın sen ne
zaman ses olursun ne zaman anlaşılabilir
kolay uyumlu olursun o zaman biz seni
dinlemeye açarız ne zaman gürültüsünün
topluma ait değilsin ne zaman s
ve toplum Sunway Biz topluma ait olan
insanlar ancak sesimizi duyurabiliriz
ozgül Tüh olduğumuz zaman vızıltı yız
gürültü yüz Sen su Siz gürültüyü ne
olursa olsun bir noktada susturmak
istiyoruz gürültü kafamıza geldiği zaman
Susma tutması gereken bir şey bir adım
daha atayım
Evet şimdi size Anneme bile bilmediği
bir şey soracağım ben çok geldiğim zaman
Kafamda iç seslerin konuşmaya başlıyor
bu vızıldama ya başlıyor ve Bayağı da
güçlü bir şekilde hız diyorlar ve beni
çok rahatsız ediyorlar Ben de bir süre
önce bir teknik geliştirdim dedim ki
kafamda Bu sesler hızlanmaya başladığı
zaman dur diyorum
mı duruyor
daha sonra tekrar çıkı sonra Konuşmaya
başladılar yine hatırlatıyorlar bana
hatırlıyor musun oyun orta iki sınıfta
yaptığım s**** şey ne kadar rezil
olmuşsun ha ha diyebiliyorlar bana sonra
ben dur diyorum duruyorlar ama sonra
tekrar çıkalım ve gün duş tayım aklıma
bir fikir geldi en güzel fikirlerle
gelir bu da gelir bu
bu Ruslar tekrar başladı
Bu kişiler diyorlar dinlemek istemiyorum
ama çok Bağırıyorlar Bu sefer tamam
dedim Ne istiyorsun söyle bana ne
istiyorsun dinleyeceğim Seni dedim
söyledikleri kaç yaşıyordu dinledikten
sonra sen gel gibisin bana sordukları
tek şey buydu ağzı metaforlar
veriyorlardı hatırlatıyorlar bir şeyler
ama söyledikleri Aslında tek şey Benim
gergin olduğumu Ben gergin olduğumu
ancak gürültülü dinleyerek Anladım ona
dur diyordum duruyordu ama sonra tekrar
çıkıyordu dur diyordum duruyordu ama
sonra tekrar çıkıyordu bir şey dur
diyerek gürültüye dur diyerek onu
sindire meyiz ne zaman dinlemeye
başladım ben anladım ki ben kendim
gerginim ve bu konuda Belki bir şey
yapabilirim ne yapabilirim Hadi tasyonu
yapabilirim Belki belki oturup
sakinleşebilirim bir şey yapabilirim ne
yaptım öne
o önemli olan benim onu anlamış olma ama
onun bana söylediği Beni korkutan
gürültünün söylediği tek şeyin Benim
gergin olduğunu söylüyor olması sonra
ben onu anlamış olmam ve artık onun
gürültü olmaması artık o bir ses beni
uyaran bir Ses gürültü değil ne zaman
dinlemeye başladım O zaman ses olmaya
başladı gürültüyle ses arasındaki fark
ile dinlemekle duymak arasındaki fark
O çok yakın birbirine
bir gürültüyle ses arasındaki tek fark
otorite dinlemekle duymak arasındaki tek
fark bir şans vermek Ben ne zaman bir
şans vermeye başladım içimdeki sese o
zaman dinledim dinlemeye başladım O
zaman duymaktan dinlemeye geçtim O zaman
Gürültü ses oldu anlayabileceğim bir şey
oldu karmaşık birşey olmadı su duymak ve
dinlemek arasındaki tek şans Tek fark
şans vermek Biz biz ne zaman bir insanla
konuşurken bir cümleyi daha dinleye
biliyorsak ona bir şans daha veriyoruz
Eğer bir cümleyi daha dinleye Biliyorsun
ona bir şans daha veriyoruz aslında bir
konuşma bir diyalog sadece şanzıman şans
veriyoruz her dinlediğimiz an şans
veriyoruz
bu Eğer duymaktan dinlemeye geçmeyi
başarabilirsek pek etrafımızdaki seslere
bir şans veririz iş arkadaşlarımıza bir
şans veririz Belki patronunuz bize şans
verir belki Böylece kendi içimizdeki
torunları çözebiliriz etrafımızdaki
sorunları çözebiliriz dünya barışına
kadar her şeyi dinlemekle başlayarak
çözebiliriz O yüzden gürültü dinleyin
Çok teşekkürler Erbaa